okay so the topic of this short video is
your sense of taste so let's go ahead
and get started well first of all I want
to address kind of the myth that there
are certain areas of the tongue that
detect flavor well you can dispel this
myth very quickly by just trying this
you know put something salty at the tip
of your tongue according to the map you
shouldn't be able to taste the saltiness
you should only be able to taste things
that are sweet at the tip of your tongue
so we have the ability to sense all of
these flavors all throughout our tongue
so this map that you see here is kind of
outdated
although the tongue can detect five
basic flavors salty sour sweet bitter
and umami which is savory well let's
talk about more how your tongue works
your tongue has thousands of tiny little
bumps that you can see these bumps these
are not your taste buds we'll get to
those in a moment these are known as
poppy lay and if we go ahead and zoom on
into the tongue we can actually see an
individual poppy lay right here one of
those individual bumps and so what are
the taste buds come in well each of
these papillae has dozens of taste buds
you can see I've just labeled them right
there in the picture and if we zoom out
even further we can see that every
single taste bud is made up of a few
dozen cells and these cells are called
the taste cells now these are chemo
receptors these are the the cells that
detect the chemicals in the foods that
we eat so here again every taste bud is
made from several about a dozen or so
what are called taste cells and so the
way we detect flavor is imagine you've
just taken a bite of something that
you're chewing it and it's mixed into
this saliva that's in your mouth so
molecules from your food will begin to
break down and dissolve in your saliva
you know there also you also have
enzymes that can aid in breaking down
and what happens is well you know let me
add some saliva to my animation
here and as we chew the molecules in our
food begin to dissolve and they dissolve
and actually well diffuse into those
taste cells the molecules from our food
will dissolve and diffuse into the taste
cells and once that happens the T cells
will generate an electrical impulse an
action potential and the action
potential as we learned and another
topic or travel down cells through the
nerves and eventually in this case the
impulse or the action potential will
travel up several of me what are called
the cranial nerves which lead directly
into our brain and this is how our brain
then interprets the flavors and the
foods that we are eating so there you
have it a pretty quick video there on
how we detect our how we detect various
tastes so go ahead and pause the video
and you know try to answer these
questions and if you're in my class I'm
happy to check your answers before
school or after school thanks for
watching